so i'm brandon bloom we're talking about
dendrology which uh dendrology is the
study of trees
um
i actually didn't know this word
and then uh
once upon a time in the in the closure
irc channel oh sorry hit the button too
many times
um
gary fredericks
said this to me he said
b bloom is a dendrologist because i was
talking about processing trees and i
just loved this i laughed really hard
when uh when gary uh said this um
because as as functional programmers we
work with trees a lot and so we all
really should be dendrologists and we
should be obsessed with trees and
studying them and understanding them
so for uh and here he told us the
closure bot who said i think it's a
german for all right so closure bot now
knows
that i'm a dendrologist
uh which just makes me giggle uh
occasionally
so um for this talk i'm gonna assume
that you guys being closure folks
you like data
you like immutability
you like values you like all of these
things
and so what i'm arguing is that this
means you really like trees so
so trees give you all those things in
many ways and it makes them possible and
so i want you to kind of have like a new
appreciation for trees
and
a few more tools to think about them
so the problem is that
even though we generally prefer to work
with trees the real world is not tree
shaped usually
it's this big spaghetti mess
and this little piece of parsley in the
middle here is your beautiful functional
program
right now i could not have found better
clip art this is the best clip art ever
i found this and i giggled harder than
when gary told me i was a dendrologist
um so i'm gonna help you untangle the
spaghetti in your brain
um and so i realized i had a lot of
stuff to say about this like techniques
and tools and tricks
but what i realized is that i just want
to give you some some
two mental tools to help you untangle
trees uh they aren't gonna be as
detail-oriented of like do this and that
to process a tree these are sort of like
more higher level thoughts that i'm
gonna go through that hopefully will
enable you to have a new appreciation
for what is a tree how you design a tree
how you work with them at a conceptual
level
so uh first
what's a tree anyway well here's a tree
this is a tree uh i've labeled it in
breath first order a b c d e f g
it's got you know it's variation you can
have different number of nodes whatever
right you'll notice that all the
pointers go from parents to their
children
this is also a tree with all the
pointers going from children to their
parents
uh this is a different type of tree
not going to talk about this type of
tree today this is what you see when you
work with a database or the relational
model or whatever
but the building blocks we're going to
talk about today are all the pointers
going from parents to children so this
is this is sort of the the functional
data structure trees that we're used to
so
that's like the first thing those are
those are different remember that
uh the parent is implicit from context
so i'm thinking that the parents have
their pointers down to their children so
in this diagram each of these lines are
pointers here
this is also a tree
this is a degenerate case of a tree this
is a linked list
right but
this two here is a tree so some people
like don't think about it that way but
but it is
so is this a tree
well
um this is a
graph it's a directed acyclic graph
and i'm going to make the argument that
this is as good as a tree so the reason
this is as good as a tree is because
there's a canonical serialization
you can just think of copying d from the
perspective of traversing
and in that case it's effectively the
same as having a tree and there's
considerable advantages you can have by
having the structural sharing that
occurs with a directed acyclic graph so
this is an optimized tree
you can think of it that way even though
it's technically a graph
so next question is is this a tree
and this one is definitely not a tree
this is a cycle this is for sure a graph
and this is not even an optimized tree
this is this is not a tree at all
and the problem with this is that you
don't know where one tree starts and
another tree ends if you want to think
about this as a tree
here's a real tree
this is called a banyan tree does
anybody who knows what a banyan tree is
okay
so a banyan tree grows
a trunk and then it grows down vines and
this is one giant banyan tree
and it grows all these vines down and
they reach the ground and they turn into
new roots and they grow into new trunks
this is a mess where does one tree start
in the next tree end whoever named this
thing was like a crappy dendrologist
because this
this is a banyan graph
is what this actually is
and
so
so you don't want to like accidentally
have your trees grow new roots and
inadvertently create graphs
and like you thought you had a tree and
then you don't
so um the argument i'm going to make
about this
is that pointer cycles are the root of
all evil
and the reason they're the root of all
evil is because they're also the tail of
all evil
because you you can't tell
where where one cycle begins you can't
you don't have an obvious starting point
you don't have an obvious canonical
serialization
um
pointer cycles are just they're just
freaking evil and i want to kind of
explain to you why and and make sense of
that for you
so here's a the direct basically graph
we saw from before
um in this case this orange thing here
is like an atom or like a loop variable
this is the pointer to the root of the
tree
um
this green thing up here this notation i
invented just saying i want to replace d
through the path of b and rewrite it to
b e
so this is green highlighted part here
saying i've got this path from b to d
and i want to rewrite at this path
so if i
like do a swap on my atom or whatever it
is i do
and i rewrite this and i got a prime b
prime and and my new e here you'll
notice i'm
preserving structural sharing and i got
a happy case where i efficiently only
had to copy the path
and everything is is fine and dandy
but
if i've got a cycle and i have a pointer
to some point which is not necessarily
the root right it's just a part of the
cycle
and i want to change this path b to d
and i do this i have to copy the entire
cycle
and that's true of this small case but
that's also true of
all cycles ever right even like this
trivial example like you can come up
with ones where it's not a big deal or
whatever but the the fact of the main is
that when i have a cycle if i want to
change something in the cycle
i have to rewrite the entire cycle
so uh
how many people
know what this is have seen a system
that looks like this how many how many
people have written
this before
more hands should be up you have all
done this
every one of you have done this
this diagram
keeps me up at night
this is this simple
single parent pointer in the code right
i've got the parent pointer in my code
just one in the code there's literally
one pointer going the wrong direction
and at runtime it turns into all these
other up pointers
and you have this cluster
of nodes and if i want to change g to g
prime
i have to copy the entire tree
stop doing this
stop making graphs like this stop
putting this one dopey up pointer that
ruins
the beautiful nature of a directed
acyclic graph
right and turns it into a cyclic
spaghetti mass banyan tree thing just
stop doing it
right this is the one vine that came
down and started the new route
so like i said
pointer cycles are evil
but i want to go further than that i
want to say that pointers are evil just
straight up all pointers conceptually
they're the wrong model and they're a
really serious problem semantically for
your programs
let's uh let's come back and talk about
that in a bit um
yeah we'll we'll come back to that
it's an excellent question
uh you'll
find out in a moment
so
the reason uh pointers are are evil it's
just conceptually
um
they're problematic because they're
their identities and so
what happens here let's say i have this
graph
okay in this case this orange thing here
is like a cross reference or some other
sort of node it could be a parent
pointer or whatever
pretend this is for example um
a research paper and this is like like a
like a latex document and this is like a
section reference like in section d
please see section b right this is a
cross reference if i wanted to change b
to b prime
i have a problem
because d is still pointing to the old b
and so
if i were to like traverse down this
graph and follow this pointer
i have an old version of b and so now
there's two versions of b in my research
paper like that's a problem
so i don't want this to be a pointer i
want this to be like a dotted line a
pointer reference whatever i don't want
this to be a fixed
relationship with a pointer to here
because if i do another transformation
right
uh
or so sorry so i want i want b prime
here to be what i point to in the
context of this orange arrow so
when i make the change from b to b prime
i also have to move my root pointer to
that new tree and now i can interpret
this cross reference by the name b
instead of by the pointer to that object
and so if i do another transformation
i don't have a problem now somebody else
can currently and another thread another
function whatever can do another
transformation and doesn't have to worry
about this problem happening like i
don't have to worry about this being
rewritten because i'm interpreting this
in the context of that
so i can use the name b
like a pointer as long as i have a
context to interpret it
you have to add level in direction
precisely
and that's exactly what you do with a
mutable pointer if for your atom or
something at the top right
so uh
i stole this slide from richie
shamelessly
and i put his face down here so you know
so this dotted box here
is an identity right and you do
perception of it and it's values over
time
and so we all know that in closure we
have atoms and
agents and refs and other types of
identities but
we actually have two identities
in this diagram
there's this first one on top right that
is this is the identity of the current
version of the tree
and then there's this one here the
pointer to b the pointer the the cross
reference the b
so we have two identities here and
they're not necessarily atoms or refs or
agents
so now your question about pointers and
references and things
uh let's talk about them i'm sorry the
first bit of code i'm going to show on
the screen is c plus
it's actually not really c plus plus
because there's this like swear word
thing here i didn't know what to put
there i don't think this is totally
invalid but i just i figured this
illustrates the point better than
closure would
here's a pointer class right if imagine
for a moment
c plus plus didn't have pointers for
some reason
um i have my global memory right at the
top
uh i've got a pointer some class t i
construct that pointer with an integer
or a long
i have this draft function right this is
the at sign enclosure this is how you
deref a reference or an identity
i do some voodoo to get out of t that is
combining the memory and this pointer
i can do pointer arithmetic right
because i know the concrete
representation of a pointer so i can
like add something to it and get another
pointer to another object
and all i had to do is hold on to that
pointer value and i can interpret that
in the global memory at some point in
time
but uh
if we
ignore the fact that it's a pointer and
talk about it as a reference instead we
get rid of the arithmetic because we no
longer have the knowledge of the
concrete representation we're no longer
leaking that fact
um we can do more things with this
pointer now uh as a reference we can
pin memory and garbage collect and do
other things that you couldn't do if
somebody was doing arithmetic on the
pointers
and so
this is a different abstraction than a
pointer and it's effectively the same
thing i just got rid of that operation
but the question now is we still have
this global memory
and so what happens if we thought about
this without the global memory
well we still need memory here from
somewhere
so
one way we can get it is we can
construct the reference with memory
right we can store it as a secondary a
second uh
member of this object and now i have a
pointer and if i dereference this
pointer i always get
the same value in memory and if i want
that pointer to represent a succession
of values over time then i need to
mutate memory right
and so this d ref here doesn't change
the pointer but memory may change over
time and so
this thing i can pass around and it
points to a particular place
in the memory it was initialized with
which may or may not change
but we're functional programmers and so
we like to have immutable things so if
we have immutable memory this reference
is useless to us because if memory
doesn't change then every time we
dereference it we get the same thing
every time it's not a succession of of
states it's just one state
so we can move that argument to duref
so now this has two arguments the
current self the reference and and
memory right
like this we only have the one p private
whatever in theory we could have
different things implement this direct
interface but this direct takes an
argument which is memory that's the
context
in which this reference is being
interpreted
so
if you want to think about this in
closure terms you've got your igref
right this is this is what atoms and
thunks and other things implement
uh sorry late
delays refs agents etc
you could imagine a protocol idi ref in
it's just like duref but it takes an
extra argument of context
right
and so this is how much more concise the
closure is in the c plus i can do my
voodoo magic here but basically i take a
private p and i want this protocol to f
in some context memory right so memory
here is context for this instance of
this abstraction
so uh let's do a concrete example of
this uh
yeah
precisely
no you wouldn't yeah i mean you could if
you wanted to right so there's no reason
you can't make a bite array if you have
some knowledge about some case that that
like
would benefit you to do that
generally not no no it's just to make
that analogy so here's here's a more
realistic example of this
dbref the ddraft takes a table and an id
and then it's evaluating the context for
the context of the database right so
i can make an object that i pass around
that if i call draft in i have to give
it the database and this gives me the
current for example
user five we branded give me the current
brand in this database or that database
or this database
but generally you wouldn't do this
either this is just again to make to
make that
that analogy so what you would really do
is you'd not bother with that
abstraction at all and you just write a
get user function
but the point here is that
that in this case five
right represents brandon in the context
of this database with get user which has
this part of the context et cetera
this is an identity too right this is an
identity this is only meaningful in the
context of like an http request
this is an identity right this is
meaningful in the context of like a
database or whatever but
you you need to know more stuff to be
able to reference this you can't just
assume global memory
this is
an identity two you know this is brandon
this is me in the database but you only
know that in the context of the previous
slides
so
you have identities everywhere in your
software
and
you just gotta remember the context and
that's and so i'm gonna give you a way
to remember to think about the context
all the time when you're working on your
entities
context is king
and when someone asks you tomorrow
you're like how was the talk and you're
like it was good let me put the burger
king on the slides then it really
creeped me out
and somebody was like
why was burger king on the slides what
was the context of that you'll say
exactly
context is king
so just remember to think about context
you're never going to forget that now
because of that creepy face
typed in king
wanted to like cry didn't sleep it's
terrifying this is anybody else does
this creep anybody else out anybody i'm
sorry
um
so uh let's talk about uh symbols just
to give you like a concrete example what
we've been talking about give the
database example talk about symbols
they're they're sort of the original
identity like before rich ever talked
about the apocal time model right like
less programmers since the 60s use
symbols as identities
so
here's a piece of nonsensical closure
code
you'd never write this but it's just to
illustrate the point
x doesn't do anything right it's this
top level x it gets returned this whole
thing can be simplified down to like a
function that returns local but the
point of the matter is that if i were to
compile this for example the closure
script
which is
a great example of how to like process
trees go look at the closure script code
the way they handle context is like
mind altering how simple they made it
if you process this in context
this x even though it's the same x as
this one they're different in context
and so you need to thread context
through your analyzer your compiler your
code generator to be able to do these
things
this x is a var this x is a local
at one time they're both the symbol x
right but they mean different things in
context
and so
you can produce your contextually symbol
resolved here right and so at this point
in time when compilation is occurring
right that's that x not this x
but context is not just about
identities
there's other context that takes place
in this compiler situation for this
particular example this one's a
statement and this one's an entail
position and so therefore because this
is intel position we need to return
right so it's really really really
important that you think about context
when you think about
trees and working out trees
identities in context so uh
give you a couple more examples just to
think about like what else is in context
it does so when i started so i came up
with a title for this talk and i started
i started i had so much stuff to say
about trees
there's just so much stuff um and so i
decided that i just wanted to get across
uh context and identities today and so
like there's about like a million
follow-up questions and i could
literally ramble about trees for a month
um but i just like wanna like i wanna
get you thinking about them sort of the
way i think about them because i think
it's a useful way to think about them um
and so
and so uh let's let's look at some
examples of of context in action uh
we've talked a little bit about
identities in context symbols et cetera
databases whatever we're talking a
little bit about just like some of the
mechanics of context um that you may or
may not be thinking about like what like
there's context that you should be
thinking about that you're overlooking
so i'm gonna kind of like try and spell
it out
um here's a vector encoding of this tree
basically it's a variatic vector the
first element is the label and then the
rest of elements are the children
this is nice and concise uh you can see
it reads in breath first order
um
you can you can encode your trees this
way
you can work with trees this way
this is basically the same as your lisp
code is right it's a big tree list
do not do this do this instead
make your stuff out of extensible maps
like everybody starts like lisp and they
like build tons of con cells and
whatever and then like you see people
that do ml and haskell papers and they
have a new abstract data type and then
they're like well half the problem is
that they have like a tree with
decorated with numbers and they want to
decorate it with different numbers and
they're like i don't even got a data
type for that we're good this is like
ridiculous because you're eventually
going to want to decorate it with two
numbers
and so like just always start with this
this this representation just use
extensible maps
closure loves maps maps are good for you
extensible is good for you in terms of
your data just like always start with
this representation you can layer this
representation on top if you need that
syntax just just don't start there
because you're just gonna like struggle
and then
like all i'm gonna do is just associate
another key my life's gonna be easier
so
that's like a practical thing enclosure
so um let's write some simple functions
that do just that like annotate the tree
with some context
so here i want to label all the nodes
with their depth
a is at depth 0 bc and d are at 1 e f
and g are at 2
so the function takes a node
and then it's just a very simple
recursive algorithm this is super easy
we have the recursive component f we
started off with a node and the initial
value zero
we create a little function for
annotating our children we attach the
depth onto our node like i said
extensible maps makes your life easy
right then we just like recurse into all
the children and
you know throw the their depth on them
with the incremented depth
here depth is your context right
depth could be a map right so closure
does this uh the closure compiler that i
mentioned earlier does this where they
thread through you know
a lot of context data in an extensible
map here it's just an integer you know
it might be a map with like four or five
keys whatever i could i could stitch it
onto the node itself and a context key
like whatever it is the point is you got
to realize that like you have to thread
some context through this traversal
and we have it on the way down so we're
able to like associate the node on the
way down to this traversal
uh
i said that
here's a different function
uh i'm just going to make a couple these
are these are pretty simple examples i
just want to make a point with all this
stuff in a bit
basically um here i want to annotate the
max depth so these branches are max
depth 2
and this branch in the middle here is
max f1 and let's assume we already have
our tree decorated with depths so we
have
the same sort of simple recursive
function where we get the max if we're
in an interior node we get the max of
all the depths of our children otherwise
if we're at a leaf we just stick max
depth on there which is the current
depth
and so this is an example of
passing context back up the traversal
um we have the depth at the bottom but
we have the depth at the bottom but uh
we don't have it till the way out of the
traversal we don't have it on the way
into the traversal so instead of it
being an argument it's a return value
it's part of node itself as an
extensible key it's part of the return
though
um so let's look at something a little
bit trickier so
this is way trickier than you think it
is
i started looking for a simple example
to explain some of this stuff and like i
was blown away that was like actually
like research on like such simple
problems
so if i wanted to number this tree depth
first right i gotta like follow along
that pattern right that's the depth
first traversal shape
right um
it's actually involves passing the
current index down and the number of
children up essentially right
yeah you had a funny look at your face
you got it depth yeah so it's going to
print out if i were to print these they
print like this
so it turns out to be pretty tricky
actually to number a functional tree
like this uh because what you need to do
is you need to keep all the nodes above
you to like stick stuff back into them
when you're done it's actually much
easier just to print it out so we'll do
that first and then we'll we'll like
think about the traversal and then we'll
think about the traversal plus putting
it back together at the end
here's printing these nodes depth first
recursive
same idea recursive function initial
value of zero we're returning nil we're
not returning the tree we're just
printing it out we're gonna print the
label and the index and then we're gonna
loop for all the children and then
recurse
um like i said uh we're not returning
the tree here yet
so if i want to actually label the tree
i'm sorry i did it did we have enough
time to read this it was like people
know how to do a depth first recursive
reversal pretty easy
yeah
yeah prefix yes
so here now we want to label the tree so
this is trickier because we need to keep
those nodes above us
like on hand
so
here's our initial step with zero we're
passing in
the index then we're doing
like we don't have the value yet to like
label the next node the sibling so like
we know on the way down the current
index but we don't know like the max
index yet so we have to like go to our
children and we need to thread through
all the children this i value and then
we need to like pull that out as an
argument which goes to max index that we
stick on the thing so like we got a pass
index down through the tree and we got
to pass max index up through the tree
right
and so
this is starting to get kind of hairy
and ugly
and like
you can
so
so the problem here is that you're
threading a value
through
um
you're threading a value through here
where you need to you need to like pass
the value down and up so if i were using
instead of reduce
right so this is this is doing um
that's exactly what's happening so the
recursion is unwinding uh here right
this is recursing inside here right
so you can write this simpler and we
will but
you see all this stuff and this is like
you have to like
have that context of the tree in order
to like relabel it on the way back out
and if you like have written
any of this stuff
imperatively you're like actually this i
remember this being way simpler like
with state
and like it really it really is if i
just use a little bit of state
right
that's what that whole function turns
into
it's like
i don't agree with that okay recursively
but basically
so that as we're occurring whatever
so so i'm glad i'm glad you said that
because that's kind of the point i'm
trying to drive to here is that is that
there's context
in the work you're doing and it's hidden
from you it's on the stack
and so if you're trying to figure out
like you want to work with trees you
need to think about that you need to
remember that like oh i actually have a
stack already
right
so
so people forget that because they write
a recursive function and they don't
realize that like at this point in the
tree there's some context
and so
what we want though is we want something
that looks like this that's like this
simple right
and like i've thrown the stack out
uh well
sorry i haven't thrown this back out
i've encoded
oh this is iterative i'm sorry i forget
what step i'm on now
uh so i've just i've just like put this
value through and i swap it every time
through and this is like really simple
but i'm still doing the recursive
traversal
and so in this case
the nodes are building up
n on a stack and there's this stack of
recursive calls that have that state
and this is threading that index
no i'm just trying to make you aware of
it right
so are you saying that it's a bad thing
no no i'm not
no no i'm not i'm just i'm just trying
to say that like
when when you think about data
structures and algorithms that operate
on on trees or just in general like you
have to think that you have data
structures you're working with and you
need to be like aware that they exist
and the argument i want to make is that
it's valuable to reify that state and so
we'll talk about that in a moment
um
so where was i uh
yes so since we're smarty pants closure
programmers we know that state's an
illusion
and we can avoid it
uh so
let's do that again following the same
pattern of like let's think
about the printing case and then we'll
think about the the numbering case where
we have to like one case where we're
just traversing it another case where
we're rewriting it
so here is a iterative depth first
uh traversal
which is much simpler than the recursive
one uh we'll work on an arbitrarily
sized tree because we're not using the
arbitrary stack that like can get blown
off whatever like we're allocating our
our
traversal sequence on the heap
and
this is pretty simple we just start
index zero we have the list of nodes the
visit uh if there's still nodes to visit
we continue
we pop the first node off we put an
index on it and then we increment the
index and go on to the children
the one thing i want to point out here
is because we're now thinking about the
nodes to visit
as a data structure explicitly
we can do breadth first traversal all we
have to do is take this and swap the
order of them
right
so instead of a stack here we have a
queue so if we swap the stack out and
put a q in we get breadth first instead
of depth first
so if we weren't carefully thinking
about the fact that we were leveraging
the execution the evaluation stack we
would have never made that realization
right
and so this problem happens at huge
scale in programs where you've got a ton
of data that's like hiding over here
over there in the execution stack and
this database and that thing and you
have to think about all the pieces of
context that are relevant to the
operations that are being performed
so um
we're getting we're getting closer to to
now now we know we want to reify state
right we want to have it and have our
hands on it
so let's imagine for a moment we're
looking at node e
and
with the iterative traversal we've got
like this like stack of nodes we want to
look at next right those are like a
stuff to our right
and then we also have to add more stuff
to our context this is the context of
nodes yet to be visited but in order to
number the tree we need to have the
nodes we have visited because we need to
rewrite them
so we also need like to have a stack of
the stuff above us
and so with a pair of stacks reified we
can we can build our tree
so it turns out i'm not going to go for
the interest of time i'm not going to go
into how you do this how do you think
about this how you do this
but we already have a data structure
that is a pair sort of of stacks
let's go zipper
close your ass zippers uh there's some
problems with the api you sometimes need
different types of zippers they don't
necessarily have but the idea of a
zipper is it basically reifies
the
traversal you have done and the
traversal yet to do
um and so it's very simple to make one
of these give it a branching function
all of our nodes may have children how
to get the children i just get the
children key how to make a new node
giving it the old node and the new
children i just associate it in turn
into a vector and then the root of the
tree
and so if i have the zipper if i have
the
the the right stack and the top stack
and some other bookkeeping stuff that
it's all hidden in there i can write
this function
which is the iterative depth first
zipper numbering function this is so
nice this is iterative it works on trees
of any size at any point in this loop i
can print out the zipper and see where i
am in the tree what the state of the
algorithm is i've taken all of the
context of this traversal and stuck it
into these two variables
i no longer have to like
like do stepping and printing and
debugging i can literally just like
print out the full state of the
algorithm at any point because i very
carefully thought about the context
so the way this works
is that all of the traversal logic and
all that stack management is bundled up
into this z next function it handles
like walking down a depth first search
and all i got to do is loop around until
i get to a sentinel value for the end
and then just zip back up the tree and
unwind the stack right so this z root
this is saying i'm at the very end of my
tree and now i'm done so this function
internally just runs the stack backwards
just like you would when you return a
value
so like i said complete context in there
so okay so
no no that's fine so uh
when you program
you have to write things that evaluate
and do work and so the haskell people
are like oh hey we have laziness we're
not strict
great that's wonderful but like you
still have a policy for how evaluation
works it's demand based evaluation if
you have strict evaluation
then you say look
i know that i have this illusion
that what i want is the return value and
that this is a function to generate but
it's not really a function it's a
procedure let's be honest strict
programs are procedures right
lazy programs are procedures as well
they're just slightly more flexible in
some ways
and we can talk about laziness i have
some bonus slides if you want where i
think that laziness is a major problem
because laziness introduces graphs right
so i can actually create cyclic data
structures um you know at arbitrary
levels in a haskell program and like
lose the ability to do structural
sharing and things like that and so like
laziness has cost as well and so i could
in theory come up with a language that's
like well this function's strict and
this function's not strict and this
function does that or this one does that
but the bottom line is that our language
we have here it's strict and this is a
procedure and i've turned it into an
iterative operation by reifying the
stack which i know exists i'm not
pretending it doesn't
right
and so and so
like i'm being realistic which is which
is a marked trade of closure programmers
excellent
then i'm glad you asked
so uh
did i lose anybody like really majorly
do people get why this is cool
no okay so the point the point is is
that is that the evaluator has some
state and the evaluator has some context
for some piece of code being executed
right my point is is that when you think
about trees or just general data
processing in general right like you
need to think about the context of your
evaluation of how you interpret data
whatever so one way one thing you really
need to think about is is
identities so you gotta think about like
number five is this brandon or is this
an integer right
um the other thing you're gonna think
about is like all the little bits and
pieces of your code that you haven't
given careful thought to that are like
hidden in places so one of the benefits
in functional programming when you have
like
everything's immutable or whatever and
you want to thread some extra data
through what do you do you add an extra
argument right
and so you took something that was
implicit before some global some
whatever and you made an extra argument
and so now you can see the complexity of
the problem like and feel it right a lot
of times like i have a giant global
that's like the current world or
whatever and when you do that like you
that's an argument to all of your
functions but it's not in the signature
of the function and so one of the
problems people have when they learn
functional programming is that like
they're like oh my god i have so many
arguments and like and like they're like
this is so complicated and that's not
the case it was already complicated but
it was implicit they weren't thinking
about just how complicated it was
and so when you take things that were
implicit and make them explicit
right that helps you reason about them
and makes the complexity apparent
and so um
does that answer your question
or allows
exactly
so that was the example with uh breadth
first verse depth first i took a stack
replace it with a q it turns out that i
can actually do breath first numbering
with zippers
i couldn't figure out how to get it to
fit in the slide and mirror exactly
right and my head was hurting i want to
practice the talk rather than hack it so
if you really want to melt your brain
you can read these two papers there's
actually the guy who invented all these
functional data structures that closure
uses literally wrote a paper about how
programmers have a hard time figuring
out purely functional breadth first
numbering
because of this problem like these are
like computer science researchers you
like like informally interviewed a bunch
of like computer geeks and they're like
holy i can't do a breath first
numbering because it shouldn't be that
hard
exactly
precisely
precisely um so actually the way that
the secret is is that you create a
zipper over a
sorta you create a zipper over a forest
so instead of having a tree and you zip
over that you have a tree where going
down in the tree is actually going to
all the children of that level and so
that creates a zipper and then as you go
these two papers cover it they explain
it um closures zipper api would not
enable me to create the nice turn concat
around
um and so i think i think there's some
serious problems with closure's zipper
api uh there are ways that i could like
tweak the api such that all i have to do
is swap out the zipper construction such
that like if i get rid of this zipper
constructor and put in that zipper
constructor then i can a breath first
instead of a depth first search um
one of these days i'm gonna write my own
zipper library because i want to be able
to do that just to say i can
um so these talk about breadth first
numbering in particular and this talks
about just in general like zippers and
iterators and other purely functional
data structures like this and so i
spelled it out a few times
uh but the key ideas of this talk like
the two things you need to like sink
into your brain before you can get into
like even more mechanics of like working
with trees
is that you need to carefully consider
identities in context right so we talked
about identities and all that stuff i've
said it like 12 times in context i've
like showed you that example and
refining you want to like when you're
designing the schema for your trees
right you're going to say here's my tree
this is what it looks like here are the
identities here are the cross references
here's what this means at this time in
this place and this is how it's
represented and then when you're working
on those trees you need to think about
like okay here's all the stuff that's
relevant at this point in time here's
all the things that influence the
behavior of the tree and this algorithm
at this place you need to think about
identities in context and if you do that
you'll have happy trees
you'll be a happy dendrologist
and you'll look like me
like that
so hopefully that helps
happen to
talk about trees forever so
thanks